yeah I I'm a pilot and I've encountered
many UFOs flying sometimes they're later
identified sometimes you can't tell what
it is just before the battle of
Armageddon Revelation 16 says these
unclean spirits they go and they perform
signs and wonders and Jesus warns in the
Gospel of Luke and it's repeated in the
book of Acts chapter chapter 2 that
there will be signs in the heavens
and a lot of people are going to be
seeing things in the skies in the last
days the Bible says that in Prophecy so
we need to know what the truth is what
to believe and what not to believe
because I think that uh evil spirits are
going to use that to manipulate people
in the last days
foreign
is leaving us for greener pastures he
actually needs to focus on his channel
strange normal if you haven't checked
out strange normal go to the link in the
description below there is some
Supernatural things that are happening
here and this stuff is not going to get
less it's just gonna get more so I'm
excited for this conversation it's
amazing you did you want to say
something no you're going to have lots
of content it's getting weird yeah
there's never a time in history when you
could have a weekly show or a Daily Show
about aliens but I mean we're we're
there and and you know people might
think that this is a fringe topic you
know why does this kind of have to do
with anything but actually the the
little amount I have seen of you guys
putting out content in this Arena
um it is I mean it's it's important for
us to know the day and age that we live
in and it's fascinating too because
right now what we're going to go over
today is the connection between
religion and spirituality what's what's
going on right now with the UAP UFO
issue specifically with Catholicism it's
really fascinating and so but before we
get into that I want to go over some of
the verses in Revelation that kind of
talk about what's going to happen at the
end of time with that this is really
interesting Revelation 13 talks about
two specific things well Revelation 13
and 16 kind of iterate what is going to
happen at the end of time there's gonna
be two things a very spiritual thing
that happens that's Revelation 16 and
Revelation 13 a very religious thing
that happens listen to this this is
fascinating verse 4 says this I'm going
to read through verse 4 8 12 and 15. it
says and they worshiped the dragon which
gave power unto the Beast and they
worshiped the Beast saying who is like
under the Beast who is able to make war
with them versus verse 8. and all that
dwell upon the Earth shall worship Him
whose names are not written in the Book
of Life of the lamb slain from the
foundation of the world number verse 12.
and the exercises all the power of the
first Beast before him that causes the
Earth and them which dwell within the to
worship the first Beast whose deadly
wound was healed worship again right and
the final verse in this chapter says
verse 15 and he gave power to give life
unto the image of the Beast that the
image of the Beast should both speak and
cause that as many would not worship the
image of the Beast should be killed so
everybody's worshiping this thing this
is worship worship worship worship
worship and then if you don't worship
your toast your toast that's the one
world religion that's forced by death
penalty almost like an ecumenical
everyone come together we have to come
together and worship fascinating stuff
now let's jump into Revelation 16. I'm
actually really excited about this this
is really cool Revelation 16. I'm gonna
go over verse 13 and 14 and we've been
over this a couple times but this is
this is interesting because this talks
about the spiritual side of things so
there's two things happening here verse
13 says and I saw three unclean spirits
like frogs coming out of the mouth of
the dragon out of mouth of the Beast and
out of the mouth of the false prophet
for they are the spirits of devils
working miracles which go forth unto the
kings of the earth and to the whole
world to gather them to the great day of
the Battle of God almighty
so fascinating Miracle working demons
yes which is really in preparation for
Revelation 20 where the city of
Jerusalem is coming down and and Satan
is loose from his change and he's trying
to Rally everybody against is that what
it's in preparation for all all in
preparation for the second coming I
think that's the second coming yeah but
I mean I think that this is talking
about the second coming but this is uh
the two things that are just before the
second coming are everyone needs to
worship something that's not God and
then spiritualism comes in and it has a
has a a joining effect that happens
there so I hear about these
miracle-working demons that are
gathering the world to fight the coming
of Christ it also makes me think of uh I
can't remember what the verse references
but it says in the latter times some
will depart from the faith giving heed
to seducing spirits and doctrines of
devils or yeah so there's gonna be a
time when people are going to fall from
the faith Christians who aren't founded
on the truth are going to fall for this
counterfeit and they're going to side
with literally demons so you know you
you triggered an interesting thought as
you were reading those verses of
Revelation yeah I'm in Revelation 12 it
says
um and there was a warrant have it
that war is when you look the Greek you
realize this is not like some
necessarily like physical duke it out
you know swords and lightsabers battle
it's a war of words
um
so I just looked I was looking at
Revelation 13 it says who was able to
make war with the Beast right so the
same word it's the it's the word where
we get the word poemic from
and in the Greek it just made me like so
people have the idea it's not it's not
who can you know take the Beast it's who
can argue whatever they're putting out
whatever they're doing and evidence is
apparently so strong yeah or visually so
strong
strong something yeah
signs and wonders and Jesus said when
they say he's in the desert or the
secret chamber don't even look don't
even go because it's going to be that
deceptive that's why I think movies that
are putting the idea of an alien being
coming to harm the Earth is just priming
people for this fight and that's the
spiritualism that's the spiritualism I
think we're seeing right now and I think
we're growing in that right now I'm
going to show you some examples of that
you know what the daily wire is yeah
Michael Knowles is a Catholic on The
Daily wire he's very prominent Catholic
he he very he's very verbose I guess you
could say about it listen to what he
says about this this is really
interesting the biggest debate at the
daily wire is not over gender
it's not over 2024 race and it's not
over immigration or the biggest debate
aliens
some people
like my colleague Matt Walsh say that
aliens are real E.T comes down abducts
people prowls around Little Green Men
and some people
are correct
such as yours truly who observes that ET
is fake it's not real and when they
think they encounter the little green
men they're most likely just talking to
demons and now there's a fella by the
name of Luis Elizondo this is reported
by the New York Post although I got to
give a hat tip to Pope head here a great
sub stack writer and Tweeter who called
my attention to this Louis Louis
Elizondo is a Former Intelligence
officer with Department of Defense he
claims he was the director of aatip the
pentagon's UFO program from 2010 to
2017. former Senate Majority Leader
Harry Reid has defended this guy and
said he actually was pretty prominent in
the government working on these things
here's what he had to say
I had one
I remember the conversation very well
um this is a person I respected
tremendously very very senior person
he's told me he said Lou I want you to
stop stop doing this
I said okay sir I I certainly can't but
may ask why he says well we already know
what it is now at that moment I I
honestly thought maybe it was our own
technology and I was running up against
some super uber secret sap and uh you
know they were telling me to stop and I
said okay sir so so it's ours
and he said no
that's not what I'm saying and he said
he asked me Point Blank have you read
your Bible lately
and I wasn't quite sure where he was
going with that I said well sorry I I I
think I know what it says where are you
going with this
and he said well then you would know
that these things are are demonic and we
should not be pursuing them yeah and uh
I I he was he wasn't kidding me but
that's exactly how how he felt so this
is a pentagon this is a Department of
Defense
official
uh saying stop looking at UFOs because
they're demonic
correct
correct correct not only is this senior
apparently respectable Pentagon official
who is so admirable that one of the guys
who was running the UFO office there
really looked up to this guy but it's
correct in that that's obviously what
these things are now what's interesting
is this guy in this interview from a
couple of years ago that not a lot of
people seem to have found uh this guy
seems to disagree with the respected
more senior Pentagon official who said
the stuff's demonic we shouldn't be
looking into it and this guy says no
we've got to look into it we've got to
go get all the data we've got to probe
this stuff we've got to find out what's
really going on
and my question is why why do we have to
do that
curiosity is not a virtue
but why why are we going to do this if
if there were which there is not a super
race of extremely intelligent ET that
are coming and they can mess with us and
they can probe us and they can cross the
Galaxy and then go faster than the speed
of lightning and do all this crazy stuff
their technology is so much more
advanced than ours is
then we're not going to beat them
you know that'd be like a squirrel
trying to beat an army of human beings I
mean we're just if we're that much
stupider than these things then we're
obviously not going to beat them
if
they're demons then we should want
nothing to do with them
okay and that's how I feel about
aliens who are really demons as the
Pentagon even admits so there's there's
three ideas here at the daily wire and I
think this is fascinating the other wire
is based in Nashville about two hours
north of us right and and they they Matt
Walsh believes that these things are
absolutely aliens and they're coming to
save us of some kind uh Michael Knowles
believes that they're absolutely demons
and then uh Ben Shapiro who runs the
place says that uh this whole thing is
just a psyop it's it's a it's a it's a
confusion distraction huge distraction
so even within their organization they
have very vastly different views I mean
that's fascinating to to hear him speak
so openly about that I mean he made a
really great point if it is demons why
would you even want to go toe-to-toe
with them and talk to them you know yeah
the only reason it makes sense is that
you believe that like you might get away
we mean you know
and I think I think that you have to go
all the way back and understand the war
in heaven right if you don't understand
the war in heaven you have no context
for for we the experiment that's
happening here on planet Earth is that
we took from the Tree of knowledge of
Good and Evil like we've partaken in the
sinful act and therefore the rest of the
universe is observing what's going on
here in this planet and they're making
conscious decisions about that they're
not down here interacting with us I
think that's a very clear Point you'd
only have two outcomes if you're a
believer in God and and you know you see
that you know that there's possibility
but alien life worms or other other
worlds
if we're a sinful Planet why would God
want them to come and watch and observe
this whole mess right yeah and that that
does that make sense and and it's the
other possibility you know I go God sent
him
no what I think is interesting about the
Lou alizando clip is he said this higher
up guy said
we already know what they are two things
he didn't just say this is my personal
conviction he's saying we know what they
are he's speaking about the higher
government positions yes so I mean I
think that's some I think that's a
credible thing to consider I mean you
didn't just say it's my personal
conviction it's fascinating because we
we emailed somebody who was
this fairly odd in the military I mean
not like not a general but
um he was a lieutenant I think no a
colonel that's what it was and and he uh
said that the majority of you know the
stripes
were catholic interesting
he said predominantly generals are
Catholic so so I find this whole thing
fascinating because
Michael Knowles is Catholic but this
isn't the General accepted uh uh uh
reason that goes with this in fact the
pope believes that he's going to baptize
an aliens yeah I've never seen that
video let me let me get to that in a
second David grush I forget how you say
his last name he came out recently he
was high up military official and uh his
his uh the the news Nation did a whole
broadcast on him 40-minute interview I
mean this is on the mainstream news
talking about this stuff and they said
that the Catholics
they know about this stuff already oh
yeah watch this
so let's start from the very beginning
you say it's a 90-year cover-up just
about yeah 90 years 1933 was the first
recovery in Europe in uh magenta Italy
they recovered uh partially intact
vehicle it's long been known that the
regime of dictator Benito Mussolini
documented numerous UAP during this time
this internal Memo from the Italian
secret Services includes crude drawings
of the uaps it's true it's real yeah
that actually happened Italian
government moved it to a
secure air base in Italy for the the
rest of kind of the fascist regime until
1944 1945 and you know the Pope Pius the
12th back channel that so the Vatican
was involved yeah and told the Americans
what the Italians had and and we ended
up scooping it so let me be very clear
about this you're saying that the
Catholic Church the Vatican they know
about the existence of non-human
Intelligence on this planet certainly
you know I'm almost like the questioning
like what is the setup with this like
why why even talk about this but if the
Catholic church is going to be like the
mother Church The Universal Church over
the world this one world religion
they have the answer if people are
asking evangelicals what are aliens and
oh they're demons or we don't know
the Catholic Church they got the scoop
so they're going to be the ones that
people are going to want to be a part of
right the ones who know the answer to
this big thing that's changing our whole
world I think if you were really wanting
to evangelize people into a a a camp of
we're either on God's side or we're not
on God's side right there's no middle
ground there aren't going to be people
at the end of end of the world that are
like well I don't really believe in both
sides you know what I mean like by
default you not choosing God you're
going to go on the other side of the
fence right if you really had at at your
heart people's salvation why would you
not want to tell them what you know
control and narrative you think about it
that's what the Catholic Church did for
a law
yeah
another opportunity to control a
narrative yeah man comes oh we've been
communicating with we already know how
to make all this work all you gotta do
is this this
yeah the the aliens are too afraid to
come to Earth because we might fight
against them so they've been
communicating with the Vatican and now
we're going to be the narrative like
we're we're gonna be the Vatican is
going to be the uh middleman to yeah the
mediator they've certainly done that for
a long time oh yeah so I think it's
really important to probably establish a
fact that's sitting around this table
right here aliens or demons that's right
I I think we have to be crystal clear on
that just by us discussing that for you
guys out there just no no we're we're
talking in sort of third person at some
times but we do not believe that there
is alien life forms on this planet these
are straight demons these are
inter-dimensional deceivers is what they
are that's right they're Liars yeah
they're making up a Allure about Allure
I'm making a like a myth about
themselves you know who they are and and
the whole thing is going to be used as a
form of worship and spiritualism this
whole thing is coming together at the
end I'm going to show you two more clips
that show exactly how the Catholic
church is fitting in this already check
this out
if you're an alien and you want to get
baptized the pope is in favor of it in
fact during one of his uh daily masses
is that how you say daily masses or
during daily mass uh he talked about the
right to be baptized and how the
Catholic church should accept people to
be baptized with open arms and he said
even if they're martians let me read you
his exact quote he says if tomorrow an
expedition of martians came and some of
them came to us here martians right
green with that long nose and big ears
just like children paint them and one
says but I want to be baptized what
should happen baptize the aliens right I
don't know what do you say to that I
mean this Pope's super Progressive and
he's super he seems super fun so far
he's made a couple of mistakes here and
there but yeah I mean and and that goes
I I assume he's also bearing within that
point if we're going to baptize aliens
and martians that goes without saying
that anyone any color any Creed sexual
orientation human first can be baptized
that's what I got out of it definitely
Sandra yeah fantastic way to skip over
all the politics and just be like anyone
including the green people anyone and
it's just it's adorable and and I
appreciate it grow having grown up
Catholic I do appreciate that kind of
acceptance yeah and just sort of blanket
statements all good I it's nice I always
appreciate an open-minded person and he
seems pretty open-minded especially
compared to popes from the past so do
you if you want to spread that message
within the Catholic church I think it's
great doesn't mean I agree with your
religion doesn't mean that I'm religious
myself but again being accepting should
be the main focus of religion at least
that's what I learned when I was growing
up Christian that you have to assume
that if you're gonna say
um
you know like the pope is going to
baptize an alien let's just
hypothetically say that you believe in
aliens or whatever like this that means
that they're sinners
I'm
bursting over here otherwise yeah
otherwise why why would you want to
baptize somebody if you're coming from a
perfect world and there really is no
problem you haven't partaken of the of
the sin problem why would you come down
here to get baptized and then you know
from a Christian perspective of it you
still have God God is in control why
does he let the sinful aliens come here
and mess with our planet like wouldn't
he take care of that with them and
they're playing it yeah yeah I mean it
really the logic Falls flat on the
Theology of really thinking this through
you know very objectively going well why
would somebody from another planet need
to be baptized yeah yeah and and so
what's going on right here is not only
are they seeing things up in the sky and
they're going well what's going on we
have to figure this out but we're seeing
physical deceptions now this is not a
new thing this is not a new thing they
had physical receptions in the Bible too
right first two plagues were physically
shown to be absolutely uh reproduced by
The Magicians
in the garden as well you know that's
right whether he was possessed or if it
was completely manifested I think it's
just crazy how they're you know I
remember when I started like kind of
openly posting about the the pope and
the Catholic church just being like this
corrupt system and and I had atheists
defend the pope and say this is the only
Christian I respect and I'm like
this is from a group of people who call
Christians Hypocrites but then you got
the one person who doesn't go with the
Bible at all says I believe the Bible
but yet we can baptize anybody
homosexuals aliens whatever and it's
like
talk about hypocrisy but this is the one
you accept because he's so open-minded
and accepting she's like you know I
think it's great open-minded and
Progressive and and I think it also you
know is important to talk about what
baptism really is right I mean it is a
absolute dying to your sinful self and
then coming up as a new creation and so
you know to say you know oh you can go
you can get baptized in in whatever
gender preference you you want to
sexually identify as and then you can go
down and come back up and that you don't
need to change there's a whole mess of
theological problems with that yes and
and on top of that one thing that always
comes with baptism is repent yeah yeah
and with repentance means you are you
are you're turning away you're going to
180 you know confessing
nobody's sin transcription of the law
I'm a full theological Foundation to
build on it you can just say like yeah
many of that it's just like yeah I'm
assuming that the baptizing of the
aliens would just be to add them to your
Church's books exactly exactly what's
the problem answers
to show that you accept them and
we should welcome them no exactly and
it's a part of this whole ecumenical
movement which we're going to see in a
second to not only just include the
Catholics but everybody else because
that's what the pope has been on the
move across every single nation to try
to include everybody else in there we're
going to get to that in a moment so
don't go nowhere but this is this is
fascinating and I may have included wait
too many videos on the Catholics and
Aliens here but I want to show one more
inside the walls of this castle and
unassuming Jesuit from Argentina leads
the Vatican astronomical research and
has recently caused an uproar by opening
a debate about aliens in the universe so
big huge I would say as the one where we
live with a hundred billion of galaxies
which uh each Galaxy with a hundred
billion of stars uh probably with the
many of these Stars having planets it
could be possible that the life could
evolve as the way we know on Earth
father funa says he is not sure if other
forms of life would be more or less
intelligent than humans but he is
convinced that the existence of aliens
is not a contradiction with the Catholic
faith there has been no word from Top
Vatican officials about furnace's
comments but some people on the street
find them odd Richard charnock was
taking a group from the All Hallows
Catholic High School on a trip to Italy
when he heard about the comments from
the Vatican astronomer I think it's
Preposterous that they're saying that
you know there is a one humans that God
created you know we come back to the
Bible he didn't create Adam Eve and ET
did he was Adam and Eve and so you know
and I actually think it goes against
what we believe as Christians we
won't be seeing seeing leans at mass and
soon but
the number does say that there could
outside Earth and he says if they do
exist they are God's creatures Trisha
Thomas the Associated Press Castel
Gandolfo okay that was AP this is a
well-known news organization talking
about how the Catholic Church believes
that there's aliens and they're good
people they can be baptized Michael Noel
says they're demons and he's very
staunch Catholic yeah what's going on I
think that's a very important part that
you you brought up her there because if
you just listen to that for its face
value they basically are saying that if
there's another life form out there
they're God's people they're not even
entering into the conversation that this
could be fallen demons that are there to
deceive you and so if you if you were
putting the idea out these are people on
God's side well then wouldn't you listen
to them if they told you whatever oh man
yeah the pope said he baptized I also
want to bring to attention that that guy
just said that evolution is in the
confines of the Catholic belief because
he said oh this vast universe and that
something could have evolved out there
so and it doesn't conflict with the
Catholic belief so we already know this
I think that's why Revelation 14 really
says fear God give glory to him for the
hour of his judgment Has Come For he's
created the heavens of the earth and the
Sea and that that message of the first
Angel is literally a creation message
giving honor to the one that created so
if you're the religious leader telling
people that yeah there could be other
worlds that kind of like you know grew
into what humans have grown into that's
not giving glory to God and everything
created or when they made it they
created things after their own kind it
wasn't just like something appeared and
grew into something brand new
we're already seeing this physically
manifest on Earth so that the Catholic
Church apparently has been hiding
something and and that's that's what
we've kind of figured out just by
talking here they want to control the
narrative so what's I think is really
interesting this clip right here kind of
reveals that and it tells a little bit
more about what's going on it's probably
the most
honest clip I've seen from this show
watch this
Vatican
Vatican City Italy
[Music]
in the 17th century pope Paul V ordered
select documents of the Catholic Church
moved from the Vatican library and close
to Outsiders until 1881.
[Music]
today the Vatican secret archives are
closely guarded and some researchers
believe they contain Revelations so
explosive that they threaten the
doctrine of the Catholic Church
you have to wonder if the secret library
at the Vatican which they acknowledge
exists doesn't have records or
Chronicles about extraterrestrial
contacts that the Catholic church has
recorded and knows happened
but is keeping a secret
[Music]
might the Vatican secret archives
contain the details of messages Giordano
Bruno may have received from
extraterrestrials
information that supports his
pronouncements about the universe when
we look at certain specific examples
like jordani Bruno we know that there
was so more to it than this
so whenever they're going to be opened
are going to reveal extraordinary levels
of details
according to researchers the Vatican
secret archives holds hidden evidence
connected to the miracle of Fatima
[Music]
interesting fascinating so but what they
claim is this is what they say this
Fatima or Fatima they say that this is
Mother Mary that came and delivered
three messages to these kids if we
really study what was going on there
this this blows my mind if we really
study What's Happening Here mother Mary
was not anything a part of that because
number one she wasn't alive even though
they claimed that she's like risen from
the dead or something what they what was
happening was this was a veiled being
they said a woman came to us and she
scared us and she told us three messages
that doesn't really have the same
characteristics as a mother Mary you
would expect to happen but if you dig
into the story a little bit you find
that there are people actually in the
school's organization that were dealing
with very satanic stuff and so this
mother Mary thing was the church trying
to make it fit into their narrative so
when the Bible says don't communicate
with the dead does that exclude Mary for
some reason no and I mean people just
don't study their Bibles yeah
exactly exactly and that's actually an
excellent segue into the next clip here
because uh if they're not um if they
study their Bibles they will know
exactly what's going on here mother Mary
is is trying to communicate it's not
trying to communicate with them 70 000
people came to the same sheep pasture
[Music]
said that they saw a spinning silver
disc
the Catholic church for a very long time
would not acknowledge what was happening
with the children or Fatima
the extraterrestrials give to the
children a telepathic message saying you
are not alone on this planet
we are here we have been here some
thousands of years ago we observe you
please prepare mankind that we will
return again
all this story of Fatima went to the
Vatican
but is it possible as ancient astronaut
theorists contend that the Catholic
Church censored the messages that were
received in Fatima
the kids were given three messages and
the pope refused to release the third
message the third message apparently
talks about
extraterrestrial life now that is
sensational
because to me to deny the revelation of
that particular message and that is
exactly what the pope did
and I wonder why
some content that the miracle of Fatima
is one of many events that describe
visitations from extraterrestrial
Messengers
researchers also point to the voices
described by Joan of Arc
received in Lords by Bernadette subaros
and countless stories depicted in the
Hebrew Bible
similar events are described
perhaps the Vatican knows far more about
life in the universe than they have
acknowledged
but does a belief in alien life question
the omnipotence of a Supreme Being of
course the Vatican knows about
extraterrestrial life but to suggest
that because extraterrestrials exist
that means there is no God it's total
nonsense
this this is crazy I mean and it doesn't
be ever so absolutely clear this clip is
from a a long series that's gotten I
know over 10 seasons it's called Ancient
Aliens and it's garbage but well it's
it's interesting that they're talking
about the Catholic church in this
instance it's fascinating that they call
themselves extraterrestrial Messengers
because angels are messengers Messengers
right and it's like they they haven't
even identified as something other than
what they're really designed to be and
do they've just tweaked the mean of that
yeah it is so subtle and crafty that
he's he's really just changing the
terminology you know there's there's
good aliens and bad aliens and they
visit Earth and they talk through people
and all this stuff but we're really
physical beings that are just traveling
here from another world and and Satan
knows he can't destroy the Bible the
Bible is
confirmed by archeology science has
changed millions of people's lives for
thousands of years he can't just destroy
and say it's not true it's historically
accurate so he has to say well what how
could I explain away Moses being led out
of the Wilderness by a pillar of fire
which was God no yeah the event really
happened but it wasn't God this was you
know primitive people trying to explain
what they saw and it was really a UFO
same with like Ezekiel seeing a wheel
within a wheel and eyes all around it
that's the lights that are on a UFO you
know Satan is just tweaking it and
explaining it away not saying it didn't
happen and that's why it's so deceptive
that's why this show sucked me in as a
new Christian trying to figure out what
to do with aliens
that don't make sense about some of the
narratives that are out there you think
about you know like well aliens have
crashed and we're recovering their
technology
take them long to be like hey guys you
don't have your act together it'd be so
easy to take us over right
but you can see that if it is
um you know be weingles demons and they
didn't take their dad yeah so it's it's
fascinating because I'm gonna I'm gonna
bring this back to Michael Knowles real
quick because I think this is it's
interesting his uh juxt's position I
guess is the word to this whole thing
because he's interviewed an astrologer
back in the day this astrologer said
that she absolutely believes that uh
this the Dead uh that aliens uh are all
of the devil and she's convinced of it
but what she says after that is is
fascinating watch this
with the whole starseed thing that just
got me obsessed with space
um wanting to find my star family I
would do meditations and like walk
through things to try and can like
connect with those beings
the star the star people
did you did you connect I've had
experiences where I felt like I saw
things and um felt things like in my
room
they were always like blue it yeah
really really strange and I have a shape
long like you like like the typical you
know kind of alien that you see in
sci-fi movie but like not scary like
light but what do you think that was
just a hallucination or a to be
perfectly honest a demon yeah that's my
understanding of ghosts
any anything of that kind of story
I don't there's a ghost in the Bible
is there so when a Saul goes to the
witch of Endor
he saw his outlawed necromancy all the
stuff that we're talking about right now
right and he goes to the witch of Endor
and he says call me a call summon up a
ghost and she says no I can't do that
Saul you know outlawed it in the land
and he goes don't worry about Saul yeah
he him being Saul and so she does and
it's a it's a really curious moment
because she says oh my gosh you've
deceived me because she calls up the
ghost of Samuel and it's a very
interesting moment because it seems as
though the witch of Endor is actually
sort of surprised by what she's done so
it raises the question was she sort of
just a fraud like a dime store Boardwalk
psychic you know who is just selling
nonsense to people and then all of a
sudden she conjures a ghost but
regardless she does conjure Samuel and
then Saul talks to Samuel so we have at
least one example of a ghost so I don't
know a lot of times when people
say they've seen a ghost which has
happened many many times I wonder if
that happened to me too when I was
little it did so well I wonder if
they're hallucinating if it's a demon
but I'm not totally sure there aren't
ghosts too
yeah it's not a hill I'll die on but
um because then you might become a ghost
Fair
I just
with the alien thing specifically I
think that's the Demonic kind of Realm
yeah that we shouldn't really have any
business playing with
and I mean the Bible says the verse that
sticks out to me most coming out of new
age is that Satan himself disguises as
an angel of Light
and that was always what I thought was
coming to me that was my Spirit guides
that was my star family that was my
grandmother you know it's actually
interesting because I had something
attached to me for the past since she
died in 2014 that because I would call
on it I would say please come please
come please come like hug me like I
would let like I would feel hugs I would
feel I would feel something near me
and
um after
my conversion if you will I felt it I
was in the kitchen by myself and I felt
it come up next to me and I said out
loud I said God whatever this is that's
been posing his grandma for the past
seven years in Jesus name get it away
from me and never let it come back and
it hasn't been back since wow amen so
wow so there's two major things she said
there one was that uh
spirits come to her came to her when she
was before she was converted as beings
of light there was two types one was
dead relatives and one was aliens and so
messengers of light would come to her
looking like aliens that's interesting
and she said these things are demonic
because the Bible says that that has
even Satan criticizes himself as an
angel light correct
I think I think it's worthy noting too
as well as as him saying well you know
they can't The Witch of indoor Condors
up Samuel that wasn't Samuel no that was
a demon that was posing as Samuel yeah
familiar Spirit yeah familiar spirit so
it's interesting that he was even
contributing that to being actual
Samuel's Spirit yeah she calls it she
calls out this thing and she doesn't
identify it it's she just describes it
and Saul's like oh that's Sanu exactly
and when you read it it says
see I don't remember what it says in the
uh King James but when you look in the I
guess this is Hebrew being the Old
Testament it says Elohim she saw Elohim
coming up from the earth like some kind
of gods or demons she didn't say I saw
Samuel and why would he be coming up
this was a righteous man he should have
been in heaven right coming down to give
great knowledge or whatever but yeah she
saw she was frightened and she saw
Elohim coming up from the Earth and uh
yeah it is interesting that him being a
Christian is saying you know I wouldn't
rule out the ghost thing you know like
this is setting up so many people like
he's got a large platform and to tell
Christians yeah you know he shouldn't
rule out ghosts you know maybe Grandma
maybe your grandma was a demon but maybe
my grandma was real you know yeah I
think it's it's it's blatant in the
Bible that says God did one of these
things gone he said this is going to
deceive you get rid of these things out
of Israel and he went there anyway
because he couldn't communicate
apparently with God you know essentially
that's what God has been violent from
the very beginning is there's one Voice
of Truth and I
um and the Reason God doesn't
these other voices and all these other
messages
so strongly endemic now he's like no
these are the ones that wait you're
astray they have one boy still listen to
you we actually did an LED live I want
to remind you guys of the video that we
did it was very fascinating I want to
play it real quick where Chris Lang who
made the uh the the documentary Charmed
by Darkness yeah he was uh talking about
it and he said something really
fascinating about this exact topic watch
this I had done a TV interview and I was
talking about the screenplay for this
for this story Roger marno's story and I
was talking about how we were gonna be
looking for a scriptwriter to help us to
partner with and a couple days after
that interview I got a phone call from a
lady who talked about how she had been a
a writer in Hollywood during the late
70s early 80s she was very successful at
the program she had done now she's
retired and she has time and then she
said you know my son passed away 15
years ago and I said I'm so sorry she
said oh that's okay you came to visit me
two years ago
[Music]
she said oh yes she said he I was in my
master bedroom getting dressed one
morning and he walked right through the
door like he did when he was alive and
came and sat down the uh on the bed next
to me and gave me a big hug and I said
Esther can I interrupt you
she said sure what is it I said can I
ask you a question just to clarify this
was not a spirit that came through the
wall this was a physical body that came
through the doorway and sat down she
said absolutely you had to open the door
she said he had his hand on the doorknob
he came in she said he sat down next to
me and these were these were the the
proofs because remember seeing and
feeling and hearing is becoming the
nature of reality for the world if you
see it you believe it it's becoming
truth it's becoming their truth okay
right and so she said I felt the breath
on my neck I felt the warmth of his skin
he embraced me and I felt his heartbeat
that's crazy that's scary very physical
characteristics and then she said he
didn't stay long
and he didn't say much he got up and he
before he went back through the door he
turned around and he said to me thanks
Mom for getting the word out everything
is light love and Eternity on the other
side wow and he turned around and he
went back through the door and she
hasn't seen that manifestation of her
son
since then I saw her son he would what
really got me about that is this wasn't
a light being that came this was
something that was that was they built a
heartbeat felt the warmth of his body
felt it seemed like his voice I mean you
got to think these things have been
around for for I mean a thousand
thousands of years and they have been
watching us mimicking our exact
movements how we talk our cadences and
they can they they love this stuff in
the Bible you you hear of angels just
appearing as men two men in white
apparel asked what are you gazing at and
then I think three of them came to
Abraham and he was like feeding them and
other all the people in Sodom Gomorrah
wanted to rape them and stuff so they
were physical beings
and and then there's verses that say you
know
be careful how you treat people because
they might be you might be entertaining
angels unaware so throughout the Bible
we know that they appear as just
physical people that you don't even
recognize as being so
and I guess well do they shape-shift I
mean if Satan can look like a serpent or
whatever or an angel of Light then yeah
he can appear as dead loved ones and I
think
they would have heartbeats and things
like that if if God is the Creator and
he
I think it has a style the way he
creates things you know yeah I don't
know if they actually have physical
hearts or not or they can mimic it for
sure right and but we do know that in
that story and that same story that you
said they can actually
um eat yeah because at the end of that
story he said he cooked for them and
they did eat so they must have something
they have stomachs they are physical
beings they didn't just put a a piece of
something in their mouth and it falls at
the floor right you know so
fascinating fascinating we're gonna go
on to this Pope this Pope that is
bringing this together you're going to
see the actual acumenicalism that's
happening here this is it folks this is
where it it all comes together this this
is fascinating
Pope Francis lost his temper over a
woman converting souls to Christ and
he's still mad
join us now Church Middlesbrough
correspondent Dr Jules Gomez Jules
what's bugging Francis
uh Brad Francis met with members of the
barnabyte order yesterday uh priests
nuns and late members of this very old
order and they're very Audrey he talked
about how he had lost his temper with a
woman who came to him and told him how
she converted two people to the Catholic
faith
tell us more about uh how Francis
recounted that particular incident
well let me quote his exact words Brad
this is what he told this audience he
said I had this
a bad experience in a youth meeting some
years ago I was coming out of the
Sacristy and there was a lady very
elegant you could also see that she was
a very rich with a boy and a girl and
this lady who spoke Spanish says to me
father I'm happy because I converted
these two one is from such a place and
this one is from another place Pope
Francis then gives on to say I got angry
you know and I said you didn't convert
anything you disrespected these people
you didn't accompany them you
proselytize and that's not evangelizing
he then went on to talk about how
proselytizing is uh the strongest poison
Against The ecumenical parts
whoa so what is this goal of this Pope
it's not necessarily to convert someone
into Catholicism but to have everybody
in their own system come and and be a
part of whatever else it put away this
movement yeah the whole bumper stickers
with all the religions he wants you if
you're a buddhistay a Buddhist hey you
can be a Buddhist Catholic you know
baptize an alien yeah anything just come
and be under the umbrella of what he
thinks is the the original and listen to
him put away your differences
so what's the one thing people say I'm
not religious I'm spiritual we're all
going to be spiritual people hey what
kind of spiritual thing are you into you
know and that's what's Revelation is
saying this whole thing everyone come
together and worship and worship and
spiritualism comes together and it's
it's just all coming together right now
we're seeing the beginning of it that's
what's exciting to me about it so I
really think when there's disclosure or
whatever's gonna happen I think we're
gonna see some kind of manifestation of
Christ come out of this UFO and be like
look when I ascended back to Heaven I
was going back to my Mothership wow when
when uh Enoch and Elijah were Rapture
they were going back to their Mothership
and
I think it's just another way that
Satan's going to explain away things
that happened in the Bible and people
are going to listen to him because I
mean they're going to these are you know
even the new agers they look up to Jesus
he was an ascended master in their
opinion and so I think it's going to be
such
a huge deception that many people are
gonna accept it because they're gonna
see it we're gonna fall for the signs
and the Wonders
and I am so convinced that this is we're
seeing the beginning of this that uh I'm
focusing on this right now because we're
seeing so much come out into the news
about this it's absolutely crazy I've
I've actually interviewed Doug
uh a forerunner have you heard of this
Forerunner guy
um and a few others let me show you what
they say about this
this is uh from my channel
I never knew that this type of
information was out there pertaining to
this subject matter but you can just see
how it seamlessly harmonizes with uh the
the great controversy Motif you have you
know these different uh spirits of
devils working miracles the problem is
that people who don't believe in the
Bible they don't read the Bible they
don't read this text they don't know uh
that when they see a miracle or
something Supernatural whether it's a
dead person apparently coming back or
whether it's an alien or something in
the sky a UFO or some encounter you know
with uh a being they think is a being
from a Faraway Galaxy or you know any
one of a number of scenarios and they
see a miracle or something Supernatural
they don't automatically think maybe
this is a spirit of the devil you know I
I'm a pilot and I've encountered many
UFOs flying sometimes they're later
identified sometimes you can't tell what
it is just before the battle of
Armageddon Revelation 16 says these
unclean spirits they go and they perform
signs and wonders and Jesus warns in the
Gospel of Luke and it's repeated in the
book of Acts chapter chapter 2 that
there will be signs in the heavens
and a lot of people are going to be
seeing things in the skies in the last
days the Bible says that in Prophecy so
we need to know what the truth is what
to believe and what not to believe
because I think that uh evil spirits are
going to use that to manipulate people
in the last days
interesting huh so so I think uh that
you you have to base your faith upon a
thus saith the word of God like it
cannot be based upon your eyes or some
sort of yeah exterior you know a
experience that's happening even if you
see strange things that's not evidence
enough that that came from God and so
you know what I think is really
important is to build that Foundation
upon the Bible and I think you know when
when it says in Revelation that Satan
can call down fire from heaven right
that was in in a direct nod back to
Mount Carmel Elijah and what was
happening was a a choice was being
needed to be made do you follow God or
do you fall this false idol and that was
enough to prove that God was the real
God and Satan's counterfeiting that in
the end to the point where he's going to
have strange things happening like that
trying to prove his existence as he is
god
um and that's why I think you know the
Bible is very clear at the end of time
you cannot base your your your belief
system off of your eyes it's a it's a
boils down to trust weirdos
yeah not the Miracles the Miracles are
the deciding factor and how many you
know Satan's done a great job at keeping
people out of the book keeping people
from not even knowing and watching mega
churches that are just saying you're
beautiful and Rich and all this stuff
they're not expecting this at all and
and some of some of the churches are
even setting people up for uh peace on
Earth at some point in time I think when
these miracle-working demons come and
round up the troops to fight against
Christ
look at look at the division that
happened with the masks and the Poke and
all these things like if you didn't have
it you're a threat to humanity if uh if
you don't accept this
minority of Lifestyle then you're a
hater and a bigot imagine when
these beings that have come down with
all this great technology and wisdom
come here and say we are going to help
you defend Earth from this being
we need to unite together
that's a Line in the Sand you're either
thus saith the Lord this is a demonic
deception and I will not do it or you're
going to side with the rest of humanity
to save Earth
you can see how
easily you're gonna be like the Bible
says you're gonna be yeah you're Public
Enemy Number One You're gonna get locked
up you're going to be decapitated or
whatever because you don't care about
Humanity even with climate change and
stuff they say
you know if you don't take action then
you don't care about the future of our
children and all that so
I mean this I think we're so close to
the end man we're coming to a point
where you're going to choose a side
so tell us a little bit about strange
normal because uh you're gonna dedicate
your energies to this at this point
moving forward
um if you haven't checked out strange
normal check it out he's got gobs and
gobs I don't know how many videos you
have out at least 150 I think and you
did that relatively quickly in a year or
two maybe just focusing on it making
sure that um you know once a week we do
a little bit more and I've been focusing
on a little bit more now so and he had a
full-time uh 40 hour a week job with us
so the fact that he didn't sleep and put
all this content out is impressive to
begin with but it is an important topic
and I think somebody needs to start
talking about this subject somebody
needs to be laying out these these
things that are happening in our world
and making sense biblical sense of them
and that's believe that's what strange
normal is doing right yeah absolutely
and so we're trying to trying to make
sense of this this weird thing that's
happening uh any type of spiritualism
and relating it to the Bible to see what
the Bible says about that using talking
points that are strange in the news and
focusing people back on the Bible and
saying we need to look this needs to be
the primary resource what does it say
about what's going on in your life right
now let's make it relevant yeah so if
you like strange things check out
strange normal go check out his channel
he's probably got plenty of content on
there that'll be of interest to you in
this vein Brad thank you so much for
your work with little light over the
years you are still a brother in Christ
with us and uh you know we hope that
from time to time we'll check in with
you see what you're doing and uh you
know you'll come over and bless us with
uh some strange content but uh thank you
for your work with us and look forward
to I look forward to many things that
you're going to be putting out there but
thank you so much guys for checking in
um please go to his channel check it out
and uh subscribe to him you know he
probably takes requests and and things
if you want to know he engages with his
audience just like he would have with
little light Studios so thank you for
watching like And subscribe to our
content if you haven't if you're the
first time here welcome and uh if you
want to make a donation there are plenty
of ways that you can help
carry this work forward and we would
greatly appreciate that and check out
our t-shirts from lightwear dot shop
we've got lots of really cool designs
that you can wear your witness and uh we
just thank you guys so much for watching
in this week
it's proven that people remember things
that they see more than what they hear
lightwear believes the best way to share
your witness is to wear your witness
flightware has all kinds of graphic tees
that are a great attention-grabbing way
to share the gospel so head on over to
lightwear.shop and check out all the
cool graphic tees what do you want
people to remember when they see you
[Music]
foreign